feel the hate within you H except they
don't hate it
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah rise of Skywalker I was not
excited to see it largely because of one
specific plot point that had been
dropped in the trailers that I hate on
principle and then just largely based
off the fact that I didn't really like
the last Jedi
although annoyingly for me the issues I
have with last Jedi aren't the problems
that people who really shout about the
last Jedi tend to have with the last
Jedi so stop linking me to videos
defending it because there's always
defending it against the criticisms that
aren't the ones that I have so you know
there you go
tangent boy that happened early anyways
I wanted to like this movie but I went
in expecting not to and when I came out
I wasn't quite sure what I thought I
kind of felt the same way when I first
came out of last Jedi so I made the
decision to not record this review
immediately after seeing it I slept on
it I'm recording this a day later and
I'm glad I did that because I really
needed the time to digest to decide
whether after thinking on it that makes
me think better of it or makes me think
worse of it cuz again last Jedi I wasn't
sure what I thought coming out of it but
the more I thought about it the less I
liked it this is not quite the opposite
I'm not gonna say the more that I
thought about it the more that I liked
it that happened it was something like
say annihilation which I walked out of
not knowing what to think initially but
there are plenty of things that are not
good about this and I will mention them
but I still kind of enjoyed it I still
am glad I saw it I'm ultimately landing
at a flea
where my feelings on this are not
dissimilar to my feelings on Justice
League which is that there's a lot of
problems here I'll happily name them for
you you can really see the seams where
certain elements of this thing were
stitched together somewhat haphazardly
but I did still enjoy it and I'd watch
it again
so you know I'm gonna start getting into
details and probably start getting into
spoilers relatively quickly I'm trying
to think if there's anything broad
strokes that I can say that isn't in
some way a spoiler I mean because that
that's my unspoiled thoughts I suppose
like just dealing with a couple of broad
things like if you want zero information
you need to stop now if you want like me
to flesh things out a little bit I'll do
that but and I'll save specifics for
proper spoilers and a little bit so that
was your light warning okay so hmm
the answer to Ray's lineage who she is
where she comes from that does get
answered and I think the answer is
stupid yet it didn't bother me as much
as I expected it to given that I don't
like it and don't think it was a good
idea I think it was even more poorly
executed
it didn't actually annoy me that much I
was just like no that didn't work but it
didn't bother me
Palpatine being back which is not a
spoiler cuz he's in the frigging
trailers at this point is still a bad
idea and I still have the same
fundamental philosophical problems I
outlined when I did my video about how
it was nervous but before going to see
it so I didn't like it but it didn't
irritate me as much as I expected it to
Poe Finn and Rey especially when they're
together which is about the middle third
of the movie the three of them together
sort of going on this on this quest that
they're on sort of hopping between
planets on the move they're great
together it makes me kind of frustrating
that so much of this this trilogy has
been marred in dealing with Han Luke
Leia I love those characters but I feel
like up until act 2 of this movie this
trio has not properly had a chance to
breathe and they finally get it here
which means I like it here but it makes
me retro actively annoyed that it felt
like their chance to shine was being was
not being given to them in the last two
movies kylo Ren worked for me and even
though they went a direction with his
story that I didn't think they would
pull off if they went there they did it
worked there's some continuation from
the last Jedi would like the connection
between him and Rey kind of being able
to see and speak to each other across
space they do some things with that that
honestly are amazing like that the way
that element is used in this film is
textbook and perfectly executed setup
reminder payoff it's so good oh loved
that so that was legitimately great Leia
I feel bad for the movie because the
word we has that initial conception
before there was a script but when they
had the general outline for the three
movies the third ones was going to focus
more on layout and they obviously
couldn't do that because Carrie Fisher
passed away now they made the decision
to use her you know her image and
footage of her that had been shot from
unused scenes and unused takes etc for
this and it's really obvious not like in
a compositing way not like Ana she
doesn't look like she's physically there
the the editing assemblage of it is as
good as it was going to be but you'll
notice quickly a lot of shots of her
from the back ie a-standin basically any
shot of her face it's only from about
three angles because what they probably
had was a
footage from alternate takes or lines
are cutting from like the same handful
of scenes so they only had a couple of
angles to use her from that gets
noticeable and her lines feel very
detached it's very clear that they
couldn't change what her lines were and
they they had to construct the other
characters in the scenes lines around
making the lines they had from her work
that said given that they made the
decision to do this it is about as good
as it could be done so the debate
becomes whether or not it was a good
idea in the first place I don't know
partially because they did something
story-wise with her that is what I
wanted them to do with Leia and they did
do it
so I can't talk about that until I get
into spoilers I think that's about it
land is fine Lee's fun that's fine um
hang on I actually wrote stuff down
which I've been doing more often lately
trying to think if there was anything
else that's spoiler-free
that i want to get into um there's there
are elements of it especially in the
third act and in the climax that are
very fanfic II and I can't get into
detail until I do spoilers again but
we'll get there um yeah I think yeah
that's about all that I can say before
getting into spoilers so that's your
warning
now spoilers here we go so like I said
that execution of of Ben I'm gonna start
calling Ben cuz that's actually how I
think of him now which shows that the
redemption story for kylo Ren - Ben solo
actually worked because that's now my
headspace for him in this movie so props
to that and I've always liked him as a
character I found him very interesting
from the beginning but between Ben and
Rey and that whole thing you know we get
the reminder where they just talk and he
snatches that thing off offer and like
that's kind of an oh crap moment because
they can physically impact each other
and then the fight between them where
like it's in its showing what each of
them sees from each side and then how
that ends with something happening that
caused him to realize where she is and
then the final payoff with her just and
the lightsabers gone and now he hasn't
like oh that's good like legit loved
that but I can get into a little bit
more detail about so let's talk about
the Emperor let me get it out of the way
my philosophical fundamental problem
with the idea that the emperor wasn't
really dead hasn't been resolved and
actually for the record we actually
aren't entirely sure if he just was
never dead or what because even though
he's back we don't get a proper
explanation they gloss over a lot with
things relative to the Emperor and I'm
not gonna say there's no answers to
these or it makes zero sense I can come
up with answers and actually I've had
conversations with people where they
started to come up with answers but it's
a lot to ask people to gloss over
because I mean like how is he back
is he back or did he never die so what
you know what's the deal there and and
now we're gonna get into his connection
with Rey because apparently Rey is his
granddaughter stick a pin in that we'll
come back to it so he's he's back he's
still alive he still got power he's been
building power he's been building on
Armada
why is he been waiting why does he need
Rey and more to the point does he
actually need Rey because they have
cilantro stanzas I never wanted you dead
I want you here like no I heard you
order her to be killed repeatedly so no
that doesn't track even within this film
itself but okay he says he's going to
like if he dies his spirit goes into her
except he seems to be building a heck of
a force with the body he's got so why
does he actually need her why does it
need to be her why couldn't it be his
son
her father okay and yet now let's
friggin deal with that so uh Rey is the
granddaughter of Palpatine the
granddaughter of a guy who in however
many films he actually appeared I guess
counting this one at six cuz he was only
talked about in New Hope and didn't
actually appear so out of six films
never saw him even standing in the same
room
as anyone who is a potential romantic or
sexual interest to him and whose entire
deal was figure out how to make himself
last forever and building a legacy fruit
that would be carried on after him was
never part of his deal so again that's
another thing really glossed over you're
telling me this guy had kids it's like
what no that's a bit I'm not saying I
can't buy it but I'm saying that's
another big thing that you just gloss
over and expect me not to question
because that's a leap that's a big
freaking leap and also this whole thing
of like he's saying all the Sith are in
me is that new has that always been the
case does that only happen if the thing
with Ray happens that doesn't seem to be
the case because once he charges up off
of them for sapping their force juice he
just seems to be able to do all this
stuff so if all the sister always in him
if that was always the case why couldn't
he force lightning entire space armadas
on his own before and if it wasn't the
case prior to then why is it the case
now it's another thing completely
glossed over and speaking of the
Lightning into the entire Armada thing
man this guy's overpowered overpowered
as heck and that is a big part of the
fanfic nature of this thing so to give
you an idea of what I mean by fan by
fanfic just the way in which things are
what are doing the exact thing that was
done before the show you but just bigger
is very very fanfic and the final act
really nails the Hatfield
more than anything else oh we have we
have Star Destroyers but there's an
armada of them and all of them have
Death Star lasers and then the the
heroes come in it's literally every
other ship in the galaxy and then the
Emperor
he lightnings the entire Armada like
wait stop
why are you elevating it to this cuz
it's ridiculous did that the attempt to
like I guess cap off a nine film series
with something epically massively big is
why it goes this big they
I'm just worried about capping off the
smaller trilogy that this is actually
concluding but I think that's part of
the problem with bringing back Palpatine
now this is no longer an ending to the
three additional films we've had now
this has to be an ending to all nine and
then with that in their heads they went
so big that I just don't buy it it's
ridiculous yet at the same time even as
I was rolling my eyes it wasn't angry
and I wasn't annoyed which is weird I
suppose if I were to compare this to the
last Jedi which I guess you have to do
the good parts of this are not as good
as the best parts of the last Jedi but
the bad parts of this don't piss me off
the way the worst parts of last Jedi
pissed me off so I suppose you could say
that makes this a mediocre experience
very even keel middle-of-the-road
except if this is good this is bad and
this is middle-of-the-road
it's closer to the middle road than to
either extreme but it's slightly in the
positive and yeah I'm kind of okay with
that and there is some other specific
stuff that I did like so I liked the
Jedi voices I have I had a weird thought
since then about the Jedi that I think
I'm actually gonna vote devote an entire
other video to like next week maybe I
don't know but the the voices for the
various Jedi and how many voices I could
pick out that were speaking to Rey that
that was really cool so I dug that the
the treasure hunt sort of thing that
goes on through the second act with Rey
Finn and Poe part of me was like I
didn't love the pacing of them like keep
jumping locations and like somehow the
first order is always right on their
tail yet I also can't pin them down it
felt a little repetitious but at the
same time it had a different feel to it
this treasure hunt sort of thing is not
something we saw in the other films so
that was kind of cool a dug that um I
actually rather liked
c-3po sacrifice that is made the fact
that it gets undone later in the film
feels a little bit cheap but I guess
that fits some of the humor that he
tends to do a plus also we got Babu
Frick
babbu Frick was great loved him he was
adorable what else have we got here
oh they a do the little new droid that
was weird especially the way he talks
cuz now I'm left thinking is that
basically how r2 and bb-8 talk this
super simple fight thingy and but what
we only hear the beeps and Boop's I
don't know I didn't I didn't love him
Huck's well I think the entire thing of
there's a spy in the first order didn't
really add much I kind of love this
death for Huck's cuz his really suit
it's really fitting for this annoying
little weasel of a character and I like
Huck's more than I think almost anybody
who I know just think he's a terrible
character I think is a terrible person
but I actually liked him as a character
and I think that this death for him was
perfect it's exactly how little weasel
like him should have died um I'm not
sure I've got all that much else to say
it it's doing a lot and a lot of it is
is very crammed together and like I said
it feels awkwardly stitched together
because it has to throw in for the plot
that it's doing because so little of it
picks up from what happened in the film
before it has to drop a lot which is why
the Emperor it actually shows up in
scene 1 first scene we have to get the
Emperor in there because we gotta get
him in here and he's the orchestrator of
all the stuff going on with benzo which
is also dumb and I don't like it but
again I don't hate it I do have to
wonder how to what degree me not hating
the stuff that I didn't like has to do
with the fact that I went in with
lowered expectations and or specifically
in regards to Palpatine have had a few
months to basically calm down on the
issue still don't like it but I've had
the time to kind of calm down on it so
that I'm not as worked up as I might
otherwise have been cuz remember I went
into the last Jedi thinking I was gonna
love it and not and I went into this
thinking I was not gonna like it at all
I'm going know that did pretty well
which is again very much mirrors my
experience with watching Justice League
the theatrical version
not the Snider cut I haven't seen that
none of you have don't lie but I do
think there was something to be said for
that
that I went in telling myself I wasn't
going to look for things that were wrong
and I don't think I did I don't think I
was trying to zero that stuff out but I
did go in with lowered expectations and
it did better than what I thought it was
gonna do so I came away kind of happy
with it it's a mess especially when
taken in the trilogy as a whole and it
is very much especially again in its
last act a retread of Return of the Jedi
but no I'm okay with this I don't love
it it's not great I still think rogue
one's the best of the Disney Star Wars
produced films and I would probably
still rate force awakens over this but
I'm okay with this which is really weird
III feel like that that in a way kind of
explains why the rotten tomatoes and I
almost never dug well this cuz I usually
don't know but it showed up in my
newsfeed of whether Rotten Tomatoes is
like really riding the line right
between 50 and 60 percent because I
think how much you like it depends on
your expectations if you went in and
didn't think it was gonna work I think
you might end up being pleasantly
surprised if you when didn't think it
was gonna be amazing I think you're
gonna be disappointed
so I think expectations are gonna do a
lot to impact whether or not you like
this one more so than is usually the
case that's all my thoughts for now like
I said I might table a video on the Jedi
overall cuz I've got some thoughts on
those guys right now but yeah we'll
leave it there for now
Star Wars rise up Skywalker you see now
what you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it bunch of
stuff to do as well because like
subscribe share links patreon hey you
also don't have to do any of that
at the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]